entré en el programa de MBA en la Escuela de Negocios de Harvard.
Yo era uno del poco porcentaje de estudiantes
que tenía formación en programación de computadoras.
Hay una foto mía del anuario sentado en la primera fila.
(Risas)
Ahora, en Harvard, aprendíamos mediante el método por casos.
Analizábamos tres casos al día.
Los casos tienen decenas de páginas con situaciones de negocio particulares.
A menudo tienen exposiciones, y estas suelen tener palabras y números
diseñados de manera que tenga sentido para la situación particular.
Por lo general son algo diferentes.
Esta es mi tarea.
Nuevamente, números, palabras, en formas que tuvieran sentido.
Muchos cálculos, usábamos mucho nuestras calculadoras.
De hecho, esta es mi calculadora.
Para Halloween, fui disfrazado de calculadora.
(Risas)
Al principio de cada clase, el profesor llamaba a alguien
para presentar el caso.
Explicaban lo que ocurría
y luego dictaban información que el profesor transcribía
en las muchas pizarras motorizadas del frente de la clase,
y luego teníamos una discusión.
Una de las cosas realmente frustrantes tras haber hecho toda tu tarea,
era al otro día darte cuenta de que habías cometido un error
y todas las cuentas siguientes estaban mal.
Y no podías participar.
Y nos puntuaban por la participación en clase.
Sentado allí con otras 87 personas en clase, soñé mucho despierto.
La mayoría de los programadores en esa época trabajaba en mainframes,
hacían sistemas de inventario, sistemas de nómina y sistemas de pago de facturas.
Pero yo había trabajado en procesamiento interactivo de textos
y en computación personal a la carta.
En vez de pensar en impresiones de papel y tarjetas perforadas,
imaginé una pizarra mágica
en la que si uno borraba un número y escribía algo nuevo,
los otros números cambiaban de manera automática,
como el procesamiento de palabras pero con números.
Imaginé que mi calculadora tenía un ratón en la parte inferior
y una pantalla como un avión de combate.
Podía escribir algunos números, marcarlos y presionar el botón de suma.
Y en medio de una negociación podía obtener la respuesta.
Ahora tenía que convertir mi fantasía en realidad.
Mi padre me enseñó sobre prototipos.
Me mostró maquetas
que había hecho para averiguar la ubicación en la página
de las cosas para los folletos que estaba imprimiendo.
Las usaba para tener retroalimentación de los clientes
y verificación antes de enviar el trabajo a la imprenta.
Hacer una versión simple que funciona de lo que se intenta construir
obliga a descubrir problemas clave.
Y permite encontrar soluciones menos costosas a esos problemas.
Así que decidí crear un prototipo,
con una terminal de video conectada al sistema de tiempo compartido de Harvard
y me puse a trabajar.
Uno de los primeros problemas que encontré fue:
¿Cómo representar los valores en las fórmulas?
Les mostraré qué quiero decir.
Pensé que uno apuntaba a algún lado,
escribía alguna palabra, luego ingresaba algo en otro sitio,
ingresaba números y más números, apuntaba dónde quería la respuesta.
Y luego apuntaba al primero, presionaba menos, apuntaba al segundo,
y obtenía el resultado.
El problema era: ¿Qué debo poner en la fórmula?
Tenía que ser algo que la computadora supiera.
Y si miramos la fórmula,
debía saber a qué lugar de la pantalla hacía referencia.
Lo primero que pensé fue cómo lo haría un programador.
La primera vez que apuntabas a algo,
la computadora pedía que ingreses un nombre único.
Era bastante fácil de ver rápidamente que sería algo tedioso.
La computadora tenía que inventar por dentro el nombre de forma automática.
Así que pensé, ¿por qué no hacerlo en el orden en que se crean?
Probé eso. Valor 1, valor 2.
Bastante rápidamente vi que con más de unos pocos valores
nunca recordaría dónde estarían las cosas en la pantalla.
Luego dije, ¿por qué en vez de permitir poner valores por doquier
no lo restrinjo a una grilla?
Luego uno apunta a una celda,
la computadora pondría el nombre con la fila y la columna.
Y, si lo hacía como un mapa y ponía ABC arriba y los números a un lado,
si uno veía B7 en una fórmula,
sabría exactamente dónde estaba en la pantalla.
Y si uno tenía que ingresar la fórmula, sabría qué hacer.
Restringirse a la grilla ayudaba a resolver el problema.
También abría nuevas capacidades, como tener rangos de celdas.
Pero no era demasiado restrictiva...
uno podía poner cualquier valor, cualquier fórmula, en cualquier celda.
Y de ese modo lo hacemos hasta hoy, casi 40 años después.
Con mi amigo Bob decidimos construir este producto juntos.
Yo trabajé más en cómo exactamente funcionaría el programa.
Escribí una tarjeta de referencia como documentación.
También me ayudó a asegurar que la interfaz de usuario que definí
pudiera explicarse de manera concisa y clara para personas comunes.
Bob trabajó en el ático del apartamento que alquiló en Arlington, Massachusetts.
Este es el interior del ático.
Bob compró tiempo en el sistema Multics del MIT
para escribir el código en una terminal como esta.
Y luego descargaba versiones de prueba a una Apple II prestada
a través de una línea telefónica que usaba un acoplador acústico,
y luego probábamos.
Para una de estas pruebas preparé este caso sobre el Desafío Pepsi.
La impresión todavía no funcionaba, así que tuve que copiar todo.
Guardar no funcionaba, por eso cada vez que se colgaba,
tenía que volver a escribir las fórmulas una y otra vez.
Al día siguiente en clase, levanté la mano; me llamaron y presenté el caso.
Presenté proyecciones a 5 años. Presenté todo tipo de escenarios.
El caso fue un éxito. VisiCalc ya era útil.
El profesor dijo: "¿Cómo lo hiciste?"
Bueno, no quería contarle sobre el programa secreto.
(Risas)
Por eso le dije: "Tomé esto y sumé esto
y lo multipliqué por esto y resté eso".
Él dijo: "Bueno, ¿por qué no usaste una proporción?"
Dije: "¡Ah! Una proporción... ¡No habría sido tan exacto!"
Lo que no dije fue: "La división todavía no funciona".
(Risas)
Finalmente, sin embargo, ultimamos VisiCalc
como para mostrarla en público.
Mi padre imprimió una muestra de tarjeta de referencia
que podríamos usar como material de marketing.
En junio de 1979, nuestro editor anunció VisiCalc al mundo,
en un pequeño stand de la Conferencia National de Computadoras en Nueva York.
The New York Times sacó un artículo humorístico sobre la conferencia.
"Las máquinas realizan algo semejante a ritos religiosos...
Conforme los creyentes se congregan,
los pintores en la sala Coliseo aportan al panteón,
ponen "VISICALC" minuciosamente en gigante negro sobre amarillo.
¡Loas a VISICALC!"
(Con sorpresa) New York Times: ¡Loas a VISICALC!"
(Risas)
Esa fue la última mención a la hoja de cálculo electrónica
en la prensa empresarial popular durante unos dos años.
Algunos no lo entendieron entonces.
Pero algunos sí.
En octubre de 1979, lanzamos VisiCalc.
Tenía este embalaje.
Y así lucía en la Apple II.
El resto, como dicen, es historia.
Tengo mucho más para contar,
pero tendrá que ser otro día.
Una cosa, sin embargo, recuerda Harvard.
Este es el aula.
Pusieron una placa para conmemorar lo ocurrido allí.
(Aplausos)
Pero también sirve de recordatorio de que Uds., también,
deben tomar su propia formación, habilidades y necesidades
y crear prototipos para descubrir y solucionar los problemas clave,
y así, cambiar el mundo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)